stop playing the numbers game and never
send out another resume instead of
betting the odds play the game that
improves your odds most people who visit
the casino are gamblers meaning that
they are essentially giving away their
money to the house over time
sure the house would keep their drinks
topped off and maybe they'll even get a
free buffet in exchange for their
donations but over time most people who
play casino games will lose how do you
pick the machine that will give you the
best odds create an artist statement
that describes your future self instead
of the standard resume many painters
sculptors and other visual artists
typically create an artist statement
that the scribe is at work and purpose
it's easy to see the difference between
a strong artist statement and a weak one
the weak one contains a lot of big words
uses passive instead of active language
and goes on forever stronger artist
statements get to the point quickly and
leave little room for confusion my
watercolor paintings are about nostalgia
and sentimentality I create sculptures
and other physical installations to show
the evolution of humankind and its
impact on the environment my weekly
podcast explores how the world of work
is changing especially for baby boomers
others who are more accustomed to
traditional careers naturally most
artist statements are composed for
creative endeavors not job applications
but why not modify the concept for
something more career oriented the key
is to focus half on your past
accomplishments and half on what you
hope to achieve in the future short is
good but it's not a race to find the
fewest possible words this is a popular
principle from sociology called the
strength of weak ties the short version
of this principle is that our
acquaintances can open more doors to
more people and thus introduce us to
more opportunities than our friends can
this is because we tend to travel in the
same circles as our friends but people
we know only casually with ties tend to
have much different networks of friends
and other acquaintances it's been
well-documented that for this reason
weak ties are incredibly valuable when
it comes to
looking for a job but even more
important than having a lot of weak
tides is happened the right weak ties
here's a real world example this
principle in action when I first wanted
to write a book I didn't know a lot of
other authors I could lean on for advice
I dutifully searched online and went to
the library to research books in the
process of connecting with an agent or
publisher I then set out the contact
editors and agents myself what I didn't
get very far most people simply didn't
reply that my crews when that approach
didn't work I started asking everyone I
knew if they had any advice or
connections they could pass on I finally
connected with a guy who would soon
become my literary agent David - a
referral from one of his other authors
who's been reading my blog unbeknownst
to me seven years later David and I have
worked together on full of books I've
also been able to refer several other
successful authors to him in a way
meeting David was a human equivalent of
a winning casino game it's a very strong
relationship that was initially for him
a weak tie the example is relevant for
much more than writing books success
isn't found completely in persistence
it's found in working hard and smart try
try again
sure but try again in a strategic manner
the point is at justice with applying to
jobs when it comes to building
relationships
quality matters over quantity the goal
in other words is not necessarily to
connect with more people but to connect
with more of the right kinds of people
stop playing the numbers game
you